[Music]
okay 2000 with black unfortunately get
another black
but at these higher ratings i need more
time to explain my moves
i want to play
let's play a very conceptual opening
let's play a carol
which is also what i played against the
cheer yesterday
yeah d4 d5
c takes d5
okay so bishop d3 so this is
this is the exchange car this is one of
the most reputable
lines against the carrots very solid
basically it is very reminiscent of a
london black white puts the bishop on d3
generally plays the move c3 and then the
other bishop comes out to f4
blacks black has several viable setups
in this
variation
but most of them revolve around finding
a home for the bishop on c8 if you know
anything about this line you know that
in the cairo
uh much like in the french the light
square bishop often does not have a good
home now if you think about it if white
plays the move h3 here the development
of the light squared bishop is heavily
restricted so in my opinion the most
uh the soundest line for black is not to
play the natural knight c6 which is what
most people would play if they've seen
the position for the first time but
actually to develop the other knight
first knight f6
and then if white plays the move c3
then you develop your bishop first okay
white plays h3
um and now we're going to have to revert
to a different system but it is worth a
shot to go knight f6 now
white has played h3 we can develop our
other knight to c6
and if white plays c3 we have a very
interesting line that i think gives
black uh a super active game it's the
move e5
white has two moves here there's knight
f3 and there's c3
and white has played c3
and the principal move of course is e7
e5 because we are basically trying to
punish white for
not uh developing their knight
early enough
now i've analyzed this this is not just
you know i'm not spit balling this this
is real stuffy five is theory
and we get most likely if white plays d
e in iqp structure we get an isolated
queen pawn on d5 we haven't had that
many iqp's in the speed run so this is
this is going to be a good chance for me
to talk a little bit about handling
the situation with an iqp we've played
against the iqp many times
and you kind of i think know the drill
by now knight f3 good move that is in my
opinion the best line
okay so now we need to decide
what to take we take the bishop do we
take the knight do we do neither well
the bishop pair is always a good idea
when you're trying to stay active
between
knight takes f3 knight takes d3 it makes
a lot more sense to eliminate the light
squid bishop issue knight takes d3 check
okay queen takes d3 coming
okay so now
the main
thing that we need to decide first of
all is where
we want to put our dark squared bishop
we have three viable candidates we can
play bishop c5 bishop d6 or bishop e7
bishop b7 seems like the most passive of
the moves bishop b7 black is slightly
worse very passive move
so bishop c5 comes to mind is perhaps
the most active looking move but it has
two flaws
bishop c5 has two flaws
so if you look carefully you'll you'll
notice that white has a check on b5
which does not win the bishop it does
not win the bishop
because black can retreat the knight to
d7 and simultaneously defend the bishop
on c5 but
the move 97 is very awkward you're
withdrawing the knight you're blocking
in your light squirt bishop
not something that you really
want to allow that essentially leaves us
with only one square
and that is the d6 square bishop d6 is
if i remember correctly the best move in
this position
now this is a nice compromise the bishop
here is safe it's also aiming at the
king's side so it's an it's on a
relatively active square
white's probably going to castle we're
going to castle obviously
and here the principled move for white
is of course bishop c1 to g5 like if
white wants to really fight for an
advantage i think bishop g5 is the way
to do it and then we're going to
sacrifice upon we're going to sack our
iqp for an open position and a bishop
pair if bishop g5 happens we are going
to play the move h6
which
as you should be able to determine is in
fact upon sacrifice but let's wait for a
white to make a move bishop g5 is not
it's not forced
you might look at this and say well what
do i know about iqp evaluating iqp
positions well i know that it's very
important to determine
who has control of the square in front
of the isolated queen pawn
and that is
definitely white but black has a couple
of redeeming phenomena factors the first
thing is we have the bishop here and the
position is pretty open the second thing
is that we have we have nice piece
coordination we have a good bishop the
other bishop is also aiming at the king
side so
the the fact that white has control of
d4 is compensated by our bishop barrel
let's put it that way
okay so here
two moves come to land
white is quote-unquote threatening to
take on f6
and then take on d5 after that
and we're actually going to encourage
that
we are going to play the move h6 we're
going to play the move h6
we are going to encourage white to take
on f6
is white better i i would i think the
position is very close to equal but uh
our opponent is playing this very very
well he's playing all of the
like topical most testing moves for sure
yeah so after bishop takes f6
though tactically minded among you might
notice that we do have gf6
setting the dirty trap that queen takes
d5 loses the queen of bishop h2 check
but
that counteracts the spirit of the
position gf6 is a terrible move white's
obviously not going to take on d5 and we
are going to be left with a ruined pawn
structure
no g takes f6 is out of the question
so white is a big choice here and that's
why our opponent is thinking whether to
take accept the sacrifice take the pawn
but give up the other bishop or
to play a move that annoys me a little
bit more which is bishop h4
okay white takes we take back
and of course having said a you have to
say b so it makes sense to take the pawn
now
why did we sacrifice the bundle first of
all we get white's second bishop two
bishops against two knights is a pretty
good arrangement in an open board so now
we continue with a very natural move
this move your hand should be reaching
to play this move your hand should just
be reaching to play this move
as some of you might think oh let's
develop our bishop to e6 that blunders
the bishop on d6
and i think i called it some of you are
saying bishop b6 that blunders the
bishop on d6
so the best thing to do is move the rook
from f8 to d8 classic move setting up a
x-ray against the queen threatening
bishop h2 check and forcing the queen
away from the center
now there's a bunch of tactics that
that derive from the fact that white has
not completed his development
his or her
development um
the knight is still on b1 and we need to
try to exploit that as much as we can we
need to try to squeeze the juice out of
the position
before white finishes the development
how do we do that so that what that
basically means is we need to develop a
tempo we need to continue the initiative
and we need to not worry about giving up
more pawns
so all of the arrows are pointing to one
move and one move only and that is of
course bishop f5 i'm not even looking at
the b7 pawn let our opponent take it if
queen takes b7 we might be able to go
rook ab8 and take on b2 and that looks
mighty promising i'm not even really
calculating queen takes b7
that just seems way too brazen way too
brazen
and there's tons of tactical tricks here
a lot of people would play queen e2 in
this position that loses the game
to bishop d3 again variations on a theme
this bishop h2 idea comes in again
queen eight okay queen e3
it's probably the best move
probably the best move
we can still play bishop d3 here but it
loses
some of its effectiveness because white
is not forced to take
so let's calculate bishop d3
i suppose white plays rookie one
then we can involve the other bishop and
put it on f4
that looks pretty promising
well let's evaluate our other candidate
moves as well
so what else what else can we come up
with here
well we have the move ricky eight
but rookie eight i'm not enthralled with
because white will play queen e3 to d4
offering the queen trade and gaining a
very important tempo for development in
the time that we
take to refuse the queen trade
white is going to have the time to
develop the knight to d2
so hopefully that logic makes sense
now i briefly considered the sac on h3 i
don't see any follow-up after gh i think
white is safe there
but queen g6 succumbs to a very typical
idea that you should you should be very
much aware of
why is queen g6 bad who can tell me
yeah g5 is actually very interesting
here yeah knight h4 right the queen 269
h4 leads to the trade and the trade is
obviously bad for black you you know the
drill
let me think a little bit more okay so i
have several other interesting ideas
i have several other interesting ideas
the first is a very subtle move
it's a move that probably is not
occurring to most of you which is okay
and that's what i see here is the d3
square the d3 square is a weakness in
white's position
we've already discussed bishop d3 that's
a very good move i think that's probably
one of black's best moves
if not the best move and we'll get go
back to it in a second
the other interesting thing we can do is
drop the bishop back from d6 bishop c7
the idea is to drive the rook up to d3
and then potentially double on the file
and try to pressure white that way
also i think a very interesting idea and
the second thing bishop c7 does is it
prepares to reroute the bishop to a nice
b6 square
where it will x-ray the king and exert
more pressure on white's position so i
think we have a concrete approach here
which is bishop d3 that's an attempt to
go for a white throat or we can play a
more subtle move and play bishop c7
i'm feeling tactical
i want us to go bishop d3 i think bishop
d3 is still the most promising
continuation my intuition is just
screaming to play this move
it just feels that bishop just d3 just
feels right you know
and hopefully it feels right to you too
because bishop f4 is going to follow and
the bishops are we're really all over
the place here with our bishops in a
good way
yeah what we are trying to do is is
really pounce before white completes
their development
bishop c7 was pretty spicy as well but
it's it's hard to make a choice in such
situations because there's like three or
four tempting options
and you just have to trust your
intuition in such cases you shouldn't
get too bogged down
in spending all of your time because
chances are
the actual engine evals are going to be
pretty similar my can bet you a silver
dollar that like bishop c7 bishop d3 are
probably similarly evaluated by the
engine so wasting all of your time
when
the chances are that both moves are
feasible is just not worth it you need
to make the judgment call at some point
it's better sooner rather than later so
bishop d3 has a couple of ideas it
attacks the rook
the bishop is untouchable
and mainly it paves the way for the
other bishop to drop into f4 paying the
queen a visit
and when we put the bishop on f4 the
good thing about the placement of the
bishop on f4 is that it is
cutting straight through the heart of
white's position
and it's making it harder for white to
develop his knight to d2
that's
the idea of bishop d3 and we keep the
initiative going because we it's a move
that's played with tempo
is rook d1 here feasible the way i see
it white is two moves rook d1 rookie one
yeah rook d1
okay now bishop f4 as we discussed
as we discussed
now what's interesting is that white is
already in big trouble i think because
if queen e1 if the queen drops back to
e1
the queen actually has only two squares
believe it or not
only two
there's c5 and there's e1 queen e1 loses
the game
to rook e8 and the queen is literally
trapped
literally
trapped it's crazy
i mean you can see how powerful this
initiative is
queen c5 is forced but then the queen is
really in no man's land
and after queen c5 we will have to try
to continue making it hard for white to
complete his development
yeah the bishop pair is just so so can
be so strong in an open border the game
is not over after queen c5 the game
continues after queen c5 we will have to
find a very accurate response but let's
wait for white to make the decision
so far so good
no it's not quite crushing i think it's
much better for black but
after queen c5 will need to play
accurately because i'm
struggling a little bit to find the
killer blow there
is rook takes d3 defense well no queen
yeah queen takes d3 maybe
is the lesser evil to give up the queen
for the rook and the peace but
the problem is in the in the ensuing
position we have
we have still have a very strong
initiative quincy if i played okay let's
think
i'm gonna take like a couple of seconds
in silence to
try to process the candidate moves here
yeah so i'm thinking of bishop e2
thinking of the move bishop e2 rook
takes d8 rick takes d8 knight d4
is the line that i'm currently stuck on
oh man we have we have bishop c1 there
but then the queen moves and defends the
pawn
there's got to be a move in that
position just looks so overwhelming
of course we can equalize the bishop e5
but
it's not interesting
b6 what about b6 let's see throwing in
yeah well b6
i'm trying to figure out if we should
throw in b6 that's the million dollar
question b6 i guess the queen goes to b4
b6 the queen goes to b4
yeah then we have a choice
i guess we can keep harassing we can
play a5 it does
it feels right to play b6
i can't quite explain why because
there's no actual it just feels right to
banish the queen
to a worse square
it feels pretty safe and
fundamentally sound to do this
so let's play b6 also queen h5 loses to
bishop g6 and there's going to be a mate
thread on d1 remember that even though
white has created luft for his king even
though white has played h3
we are still controlling the luft square
so they're still going to be back rank
problems okay now we're going to
continue our strategy by playing a5 and
continuing to push the queen around
oh man there's some cool lines there but
they don't quite work out
queen a3 okay
i'm actually happy to see queen a3 i
thought queen b3 was more annoying
i think i can see what we should do
i think i see the wind
so here's how i'm thinking about this oh
crap at night
amazingly if we go bishop e2 now it's
the same problem takes takes knight t4
gosh it looks so promising there
but then we can go queen g6
and just make a quiet move
so hard to find the actual killer blow
i'm also yeah bishop c but bishop c2
takes takes knight t4 i'm not sure how
bishop c2 is better
oh but bishop c2 does have the advantage
of keeping
of keeping
like everything open of keeping the e
file open
so there there there 25
gosh he's got this crazy defensive
resource in certain positions
so i'm i'm thinking of bishop e2 bishop
e4 bishop c2 or bishop c4 all of these
are feasible
attacking moves bishop e4
i'm concerned about knight b to d2
then we go bishop c2 and white goes rook
c1 and somehow
white is still holding on there
but what we can also do
what we can also do is we can play
bishop b7
oh i see oh my god there's just so much
cool stuff here there's a tactic that
doesn't work
that comes ridiculously close to working
what about bishop d6 yeah bishop d but
bishop d6 queen a4 that actually helps
what helps white
we can also try to trap the queen bishop
c2
takes takes
94 oh my god wait there's a brilliant
idea
oh my god this works is amazing
okay bishop c2 so we're gonna do this
here's the idea bishop c2
the point is to trap the queen with
bishop d6
we have a secondary concept which is to
drop this bishop back the queen is
trapped now it's sort of trapped white
does have the move b to b4 but after a
takes before the whole queen side
collapses and that should be good
so what's gonna happen here i'm hoping
is that white's gonna take the rook
if he doesn't take the rook that would
be like a super mature decision
but i don't think that he will i think
he'll take the rook
then white will play the move knight f3
to d4 in order to block the default this
is what i've been above butting up
against and then we suddenly drop our
bishop back to d6
forcing b4 we play a takes b4
and i feel like in that resulting
position
the the combination of the collapsing
queen side
combined with the fact that white is not
developed at all means that we're just
completely winning there
no i did not see this immediately
this took me this took me a very long
time to see i did i know i knew that the
queen was almost out of squares
conceptually i understood that but but
to find bishop f4 to d6 that's an
invisible move that's a retreating move
out of nowhere that blocks the only open
file i guess the e file is also open but
like we are trying to attack down the d
file so
it's cogniti like cognitive dissonance
almost to play bishop d6
so
rook d4
rook d4 rookie 44 okay that's probably a
good move
so we can play as our is our plan bishop
d6
b4
a takes b4
queen b2
and in that position i think we can just
drop
our bishop back where we can play bishop
oh wow but no it doesn't quite work
we can also play rook takes d4 but then
why play c takes d4 man this is amazing
defense by white no we should play
bishop d6
we should play bishop d6 that's that's
what we should do
and i guess now i goes b4
we can oh we can also play bishop takes
before and it
almost works
before bishop takes b4
oh my gosh there's just so many lines
i'll delve into after the game
bishop takes b4 i think that might work
oh
there's a beautiful line there yes b4
so bishop takes b4
and don't if it's too complex i will
look at all of this after the game so
don't get discouraged and think this is
way too complicated i promise that i
will spell out all of my calculations
after the game so here's what i'm
calculating bishop takes b4
bishop takes b4
ah but the problem is he can move his
queen he doesn't have to take the bishop
arg
okay so then let me think
no but that's i think actually
bishop takes before queen b2 is
incredibly problematic
okay then we can play bishop takes b1
but that's not what i was looking for
wowza
just incredible defense by our opponent
exquisite
a takes before queen b2 bishop drops
back to g6
our opponent plays c takes b4
we play
ah maybe we can play bishop f4 there
okay i
thank you zaizi i think
this is the most promising continuation
it it seems to me that this is the most
promising continuation i'll spell out
all my calculations after the game
so
this is a double attack against the
queen the queen has to move and you
might be tempted after queen b2 to take
on b1
you might be tempted to take on b1 but i
think it is fundamentally wrong to give
away our light squad bishop i think our
light squared bishop which exerts
pressure on the knight is a very
valuable piece
and i don't think that we should give it
away i think we should drop it back to
g6
and here i was spending most of my time
calculating the brazen c takes before
which looks crazy to open up the
diagonal like this is is nuts
but amazingly i couldn't find anything
super concrete there and i have a
feeling the way our opponent has been
playing i have a feeling he's going to
play it
it does look absolutely crazy and we
have like 400 attempts but i don't see a
single
clearly winning continuation there
oh i mean amazing
amazing offense by our opponent
if we play
my idea was to play bishop c7
but unfortunately he's going right down
the one line which i couldn't resolve
but i still have some ideas i think
we're gonna start
oh it also doesn't work oh my gosh
there there there there should be four
you know let's play king h7 it's an
interesting move
i think we're gonna go bishop c7
i think we're gonna go bishop c7
now this obviously sets a trap if takes
takes takes we have checkmate on d1
let me tell you what i'm worried about
here
i'm worried i'm most worried about two
different things if white takes him goes
knight c3 i'm worried about that
and then there's this crazy move knight
b to d2 just developing the knight
and there are some ridiculous
complications there but i couldn't get
them to work he does take okay
now knight c3 is forced
knight c3 is forced here because
otherwise we win
oh and there
there's an incredible idea after knight
c3
which doesn't really do the trick
amazing
let's see what our opponent ends up
doing here
so i think after knight c3 we should
switch to positional gear
and i think after knight c3 what we
should do
oh wait knight c3 have a move though oh
we might have a tactic
knight c3 i think we have a win
i think rook takes was a mistake
so what's the move after knight c3
i didn't see this move for some reason
until just now
it's simple the knight is in trouble
now some of you might say oh we have
bishop e5 but no we don't because the
knight on f3 stares at the pawn but we
have to move rook to d3 attacking the
knight
and the knight doesn't have any good
squares if knight a4
we have a beautiful winning tactic if he
plays it we'll go through it the most
resilient move is rook c1 but then that
rook on c1 can be harassed by the bishop
we can play bishop f4 or
some of you might notice that we have an
exchange sacrifice on f3 which white
after which the king is wide open and
there might be checkmate
but um
rook c1 is definitely resilient
rook c1 is definitely resilient
and then we play bishop f4 rook c2
i'm trying to figure out where the wind
is in that position there there there
there
gosh it's so hard
shrimp d3 okay i'm just gonna have to
calculate in silence for a bit because
i'm ex yeah fri frick roxy one played
we're so close to being winning here
bishop f4 rook c2 queen takes c3 almost
works but it doesn't
bishop f4 rook c2
takes takes there there
there there
uh
four rook c2 bishop e5 no bishop b4 rxc2
bishop e4 maybe
oh my god that's a crazy idea but it
doesn't work knight d1
huh
let's think so if we sack the exchange
he takes it
this was one of the richest games we
played in the spoon okay let's start
with bishop f4 this has to be the move
this must be the move
and then we must we just need to find
one more winning move i just can't seem
to figure it out after bishop f4 rook c2
just can't seem to figure out the
winning move there and we have no time
maybe it's bishop e4 but then he has 91
okay maybe it's a simple move
let me go here i'll play a very subtle
move bishop f5
i want to play bishop f5
i'm sure there's a win now there's like
no question that there's probably
multiple ones but i cannot find them
you'll see what the point is in a second
so the point of this move is to set up a
tactic
and the tactic that i'm trying to set up
is rook takes f3
gf and queen g6 check to fork the king
and the rook on c2
so that when we take the rook the bishop
is defended
but the other thing i was calculating
here is what happens after knight e1
and there i calculated the following
line so if the knight drops back to e1
we drop our rook back to d8 then we open
up an attack on the rook on e2
that rook on c2 has only one square
sorry i said e2 it has to go to e2 from
c2
then in that position we drop our other
bishop from f4 to e5 in order to pin the
knight and after rookie three i think we
have rook d1
but i'm not totally positive that that's
the win
it might not be the right approach by
the way
damn it he finds it
rook d1 bishop d ah
no we have a simpler one though i think
no i think we have a oh no we don't
because the knight defense oh
sure p5 rookie 3 bishop d4 rook d3 queen
e5
this is this is amazing defense
rookie two
this should be five rook e3 rook rook c8
no we simply have rook c8 no this is
winning that's i think that's it bishop
e5
bishop e5
rookie three
defending the knight and then just rogue
d8 to c8
and we win the night on c3
we don't do anything tactical we just go
after the pinned knight
bang
it's as simple as that and often these
simple moves are the ones that are
hardest to see you just attack the
knight another time and i don't think
and the thing is even if he takes on e5
we take back and the knights are
actually forked so
white can't even get an exchange for
this
white literally loses the knight on c3
and then it should be easy
honestly one of the most interesting
games i've ever played in the speedrun
and obviously a lot of mistakes were
made in this game
maybe not a lot but
one second
yeah but 95 folks
95 don't stop calculating
don't stop calculating 95 looks fancy
but we just take the queen on b2 knight
takes f6 check and then we come back and
take the knight and we're up a piece
so don't don't get intimidated by these
moves that look go knight d5 and we're
in trouble no 95 bishop takes p2
um and if white goes
anything else we just take on c3 with
the rook of the bishop
so
we will check
some of the key positions with the
engine my intuitive guess would be that
in a position like this we probably have
more than one win
dr lord mayonnaise with the five subs
let's get the hype rolling appreciate it
dr lord mayonnaise
man
no the queen sack did not work i'll show
you after the game the queen sack did
not work
the queen sack did not work
yeah it's it's over
kudos to our opponent definitely legit
and super good defense
so what i'm going to try to do
is spell out
each logical step to my calculation i'll
show you everything i calculated
like those moments when i was silent for
30 45 seconds i'll try to spell out what
i was struggling with
so buckle up because the lines are going
to be complex but if you follow
carefully it's like the game of thrones
plot like you should be able to
understand every move and if you don't
understand a single move
just ask in the chat or ask me to repeat
the concept behind it so i want
everybody to understand every step of
the logical process
okay a3
now let's try to finish the game
clinically so
generally when you have a situation with
an extra piece you should try to
simplify so i think it makes
a good deal of sense to play rook takes
c3
notice that it is important that we have
luft if we did not have luft white would
have queen take c3 and we wouldn't have
been able to take because of back rank
mate so you see the importance of having
luft
luft means uh air in german but it
refers specifically to the creation of
all so here if you want to be very very
clinical
what should we do what's the
easy move that we know leads immediately
to a win
yeah queen e6 queen e5 either of these
moves is good
queen e6 is even better because it not
only forces a queen trade but it keeps
the bishop stationed on c3
to attack the knight once the queens are
traded
then if you turn your attention to
this situation over here a3 b4 and b6 at
some point in the near future it is
worth going b6 b5 a technique you should
be familiar with called the deep freeze
in order to freeze white's pawns on
their current squares and you do that in
order to be able to pick them off with
their dark squirt bishop so
to keep this knight as restricted as
possible let's take with the pawn
because the bishop slices the knight's
potential retreating squares on d3 and
c2
forces the knight to stick to the king
side now we have two winning approaches
here the first is to basically try to
trade the bishop for the knight and go
bishop to e4
bishop to e4 is probably the most
clinical move
the second approach is to play b5 the
move that i mentioned i want to show you
how the deep freeze works so we're going
to go b5
clinical until the end right not giving
white any chances to hold
and then we go right for the pawns and
we pick them off and we notice that the
pawn on b5 can always be protected by
the other bishop so if necessary we can
put the other bishop on d3 in order to
protect upon in fact we're gonna do that
right now to drive the king back to g1
and now that we've already deep frozen
the pawns there is no hurry to go bishop
b2
no hurry at all
so let's go bishop e2 trying to trade
the knight
look at the total paralysis and
domination exerted by the bishop we take
the knight and now we play bishop b2
and that's it
resigns
okay
so here the simplest is to move the
bishop away pave the way for the pawn
b4 kd5 b3
etc
it's all over daniel lost okay i need to
go p again after this game and then
we'll uh
delve in b3 b2
b1 queen hopefully resigns here nope
all right the rest of the game without
comment
okay
once the king is cut off along the first
rank the easiest is to just bring your
king up
rather than making two queens
don't pre-move in such positions a good
mistake would be a premium of queen c2
um
not how would we how would we want to do
it
all right i will be right back and then
we'll start analysis
the remark i want to make on a general
level as we jump into the game is that
when we were like 14 1500 most wins
could be categorized by theme like each
game had a clear theme a clear narrative
a clear arc
now because people are better in the
opening
and as a result of that the middle games
are more complicated you can't sort of
superimpose a storyline on every game
most games are just going to be messy
dirty they're going to be dirty not in
the sense of like dirty flagging but
dirty in the sense of like
impure complicated mistakes
hard to handle positions and that's just
part of it right
that's part of the chess journey
is is starting to be able to handle such
positions
with a certain degree of success thank
you jud white for the bits
so let's jump in karo khan exchange
variation
so bishop d3 is an important move to
start with
uh most beginners who uh don't know much
about the karo khan
they play the move knight c3 we face
this move in the speed on i have
documented the flaws of this move many
times the main one is that it keeps the
d4 it makes the d4 pawn extremely weak
and it is critical mission critical for
white to keep the d4 pawn as well
protected as possible knight c3 is a
very instructive mistake that most
beginners tend to make
and perhaps even you've played this move
but after for example knight c6 already
the pressure on d4 becomes very annoying
so bishop d3 is better than c3
because if you were paying attention to
what i was saying earlier in the game
c3 allows the extra option of the bishop
developing to f5 actually c3 is fine
because bishop f5 ends up being
inaccurate if i remember correctly due
to queen b3 attacking both of these
pawns but why give black the additional
option of developing the light the light
square bishop
okay the heck is c3
was my explanation unclear seven point
do you want me to repeat the explanation
see the point of c3 is to create a pawn
chain
and to make sure that the d4 pawn is as
well protected as possible that's really
all it is
that's the point of putting the pawn on
c3
so bishop d3
um
knight f6
and once again the point of knight f6 is
to try to stick the bishop out on g4 as
quickly as possible
so h3 is less common than c3
and after c3 bishop g4 we get a position
that has been
very very popular among 2700 plus gm's
in the last couple of years this is like
super topical
super topical you had some new interest
yearbook articles written on this this
is like
this is where a lot of the theoretical
discussion is at in the karaoke
and
white generally goes queen d1 to b3
this is a move that you should always be
aware of whenever the bishop leaves c8
in such positions
uh judd white bishop d3 weakens d4 less
than knight c3 because because of the
pawn on c3 you don't need any other
pieces to be defending d4 because you
already have a pawn defending another
pawn which is the best way to ensure the
long-term safety of a pawn
so what you're thinking is oh bishop d3
blocks the queen and so the pawn is weak
but the d4 pawn yes it's undefended at
this present moment but then on the next
move white's gonna play c3 and protect
it okay
so the theoretical discussion is here
now black has two moves actually black
has three moves queen c7 queen d7 and
queen uh
queen c8 are all possible but most of
the grandmasters
recently have been going queen to c7
now the main move is 92
and
just like in the french
black often tries to get rid of this
bishop so bishop takes e2 is the most
popular move
and i think according to the most recent
uh assessments white is a tiny bit
better in these positions but black is
incredibly solid
right black has absolutely no targets
look how solid black's structure is
the development is good so
karokon players typically do not mind
these types of positions with black
is bishop f4 playable here now bishop f4
is a very instructive mistake it loses
queen takes f4 queen takes b7 and queen
c1 checkmate there was a very famous
game
uh
about 20 years ago this game made the
rounds i even heard about it when it was
played
it was an early fabiano caruana game
when fabi was like
2300 i want to say
so this was 2003 i was just starting to
play chess i had made one of my first
trips to the mechanics institute chess
club in san francisco
and back then the protest league was
called the u.s chess league
and uh i remember the director john
donaldson talking about caruana beating
uh drake wang who was a national master
from san francisco in 10 moves
and
he succumbed to a very very similar trap
here it is here's the game
all right so fabiano against rayquan
2100 fabi
so karo khan
also akara but that's a total
coincidence
oh it's not totally the same thing
though i apologize i was wrong but this
is still very similar you'll see why
this ring a bell
so fabi plays queen g4 queen f6
bishop g5 queen g6 e takes d5
and white black blazey takes d5 i don't
know why this reminded me of that but
queen c8 mate was blundered by white uh
by black
so
that's that's all there is to it um
so this made the rounds back then
but very similar concern the mating
construction is exactly the same
the main construction is exactly the
same
very easy to miss a bishop f4 is not a
move
so c3 is um
the most popular move but white played
h3 knight c6 c3
there is also the move knight f3 and if
you've watched all of the speedrun games
you might remember that we did face this
line a very long time ago
and back then i showed you the best way
to deal with the development of this
bishop is to play it's not to play e6
most people who don't know what to do
they play e6 and here black is worse
here black is worse because your bishop
sucks
so my favorite way to deal with this to
play g6
dual purpose move the first is of course
the fiance bishop but the second is to
put the light square bishop on f5
now you might look at this oh i don't
what do you this looks terrible you're
allowing white to ruin your pawn
structure but positionally this is
actually very interesting because these
two pawns they create a stronghold for
the knight on e4 and the open g file
often results in black's favor so these
types of positions are very double-edged
so anyways
we're not going to spend too long in the
opening white plate c3 we responded with
the principled movie five of course here
you could also play g6 this is a viable
alternative
so e5 de knight takes c5
knight to f3 this is the positional line
there is also queen e2 this is the
second theoretical movement here there
is a very interesting pawn sacrifice you
go knight e4
you sack the pawn on e4 and you go queen
to e7 setting up the threat of knight d3
check also very theoretical line
tons of gm's play this stuff you guys
can explain if you're interested in this
you're a clarocon player you can explore
this on your own you can analyze with an
engine
but just kind of alerting you to the
presence of these lines
so knight f3 is a more annoying move i
think
knight takes d3 queen takes d3 and
actually i did confuse the theory
apparently and let me confirm this with
chess bass
but apparently if i'm reading this right
uh bishop e7 actually is the most
popular move
yes no actually so bishop b7 and bishop
d6 are both popular i see a ton of
grandmasters play both moves but
apparently bishop e7 is
is is very popular and i guess black is
so solid here that
you know these gm's don't mind playing
passively castles castles bishop e3
and you get a position like this
you get a position like this
i see for example the game grendelious
against hari krishna from 2021
goriachen against vincent kymer
tons of grandmaster games here
tons of grandmaster games
um
i think that white is a smidge is a
smidge better here but again black has
the bishop pair the pawn on d5 is
extremely well protected it's going to
be incredibly hard for white to actually
win the iqp
kaima
isn't it like kaima
okay i apologize if i mispronounced
kymer
um
hari krishna hari krishna played knight
e4
all right krishna played 94. this was an
online game
well the iqp is important because it's
it's a very common pawn structure that
you should learn how to play with both
sides
and as with all such pawn structure the
iqp is a window it's a it's a prism
through which you can learn positional
principles
right by learning how to play with and
against the iqp you're not just learning
about these structures you're learning
about positional chess in general
94 by hari krishnan this position is
frequently played as well but we played
bishop d6 that is also very popular i
see 88 games in the database bishop d6
on
castles castles bishop g5 still over 50
games in the database
still over 50 games in the database
and h6 is indeed the main move still 38
games
and here there's a fork in the road
now it's really interesting i had a game
here entitled tuesday one year ago
against vitali bernatsky almost all of
the grand masters play bishop h4 so this
is i think where white makes the first
serious inaccuracy bishop takes f6 i
think is way too risky
even though technically it's almost as
popular as bishop h4 i see bishop h4 21
games and bishop takes f615 games but
bishop takes f6 scores very poorly
bishop takes f6 scores very poorly
because as you guys could tell this type
of position is very very risky so bishop
h4 is the best move
and now the line continues g5
bishop g3
and knight e4 it's very important for
black to for the side with the iqp to
play actively
so blue bound played knight e4 but the
main move is bishop takes g3 fg and then
knight e4
or even g4 i see has been played seven
times
dronivale hurricane robert hess oh no no
m has had a game here i don't know who m
hess is 2441
mobert
some people played like this
some people played like this if i
remember correctly the engine evaluates
these types of positions as
approximately equal
very double-edged black has active
pieces but black has a weakened king and
an iqp
so again
you can explore these positions if you
are interested but let's get to the
actual meaty part of the game takes and
takes on d5
now this is not a novelty i still see
games in the database with these moves
six games
rook d8
and five of those games actually
continued queen to h5
five of the six games continued queen to
h5
interesting stuff
um
yeah queen to h5 which probably is the
best move
um
now i see that alexis o'rourke and a
grand master played g6 here with black
and one of the games continued queen
takes
h6 oh this is so cool look at this idea
queen takes h6
now you play bishop f4
the queen is not trapped queen h4
now you played
g5 queen h5 and let's see who can figure
out a crushing move here for black
let's see if we can figure out a really
strong move for black so this is a game
between an 1800 and a 2300
king g7 very good
and rook h8 is basically unstoppable
white ended up giving up the piece
knight takes g5 queen takes g5
and even though white has technically
three pawns for the piece
white's development is
crap and the moment the knight moves
away the rook infiltrates d2
so black is winning here
so queen h5 g6 is extremely dangerous
for white queen takes h6 is a mistake
but uh
in the other game to reach this position
queen h4 was played
sorokin grandmaster played g5
queen h5 bishop f5 and you get a similar
position to the game or black has a huge
initiative
black is a huge initiative
so
queen e4 is a novelty
but it walks right into bishop f5 i
think the reason people were playing
queen h5 is just because they did not
want the bishop to develop a tempo right
so
queen takes b7 i did not take seriously
largely because we have rook ab8
queen takes a7 and rook takes b i mean
look at this position we also get a rook
on the second rank
this just has to be amazing for black
this has to be amazing for black
not a serious move
queen e3 is very logical so again queen
e2 loses the game loses material to
bishop d3
and if queen takes d3 the other bishop
drops into h2 paying the king a visit
the queen is lost
this is a very important theme in this
game
where else could the queen have gone not
too many other good places not too many
other appetizing places
so queen e3 makes a lot of sense so here
we spent
a deal of time
and i think i found the best move bishop
d3 just looks incredibly strong
stop me if any of these moves are not
making sense but i explained this during
the game bishop d3 setting up bishop f4
continuing to toss the queen around
continuing to use our bishops to tighten
the screws on white's position
rook d1
yeah but the other idea was bishop c7 so
this was the slightly more subtle
approach bishop c7 yeah
i was also looking at this move which
has two ideas the first is to drive the
rook into d3 and the second is to
reroute the bishop to b6
why didn't i reject this ultimately i
rejected this because of knight d4
and
obviously you can't play rook d3
you can't play rook d3
you can play bishop b6 but remember when
you are down a pawn
your opponent can use that pawn as a
bargaining chip you say okay i'm gonna
give the pawn back but in the time that
you spend taking it i'm going to do x y
z so what would be a good practical move
here for white
most of you probably are tempted to play
rook d1 but what would be the safer
option for white
here
it would be knight d2 exactly and it's
very important to be able to play such
moves
now you're saying oh but this gives away
the bomb but that's the whole point yes
white gives the pun away i would even
prefer to be black is a little bit more
active in this end game but white should
not have too many problems holding this
because the structure is symmetrical m24
thank you for the subs ten subs to the
community love it love it love it thank
you
oh apologies for that
so that's why i rejected it if after
bishop c7 white goes knight bd2 then i
think the idea works to perfection mega
rook d3
we can double rooks
but uh this knight d4 idea really spoils
the party
so for that reason i thought we have to
play with bigger sense of urgency and
that's why bishop d3 was played
okay
so rookie a traps the queen right traps
the queen the queen is no
squares because the bishops are
controlling all of them domination
um nomadic asks where queen c1 where
i'm not sure
where you're suggesting queen c1
because here queen c1 is impossible the
bishop controls that square
so queen c5 is literally forced
and this was
an important moment this is a very
complicated moment why what makes
something complicated
well
the the most like
classic definition of a position being
complicated is when you have a lot of
candidate modes when you have a lot of
candidate moves that automatically makes
a position harder to
uh process
and i hope that the logic behind b6
makes sense to everybody i figured that
we won't damage our position
by forcing the queen onto an inferior
square
now you might say well how do you know
that the a3 square is inferior well i
think i'm using a heuristic right if i'm
forcing the queen to the side of the
board the queen is going to be doing
less and i literally almost trapped the
queen later on so i think this was
justified
so if you bring the bishop back to d6
then the queen can just move back to e3
and you repeat the position remember
that the bishop literally just came from
there
so if you want to make a draw yeah you
can go bishop d6 but the queen just
drops back to e3
i also considered of course the move
bishop e2 a lot of you thought that this
was winning
it's not winning rook takes the rook
takes d8 and to the rescue
comes not this move this blunders the
knight
but knight f3 to d4 and this is
freaking public enemy number one this is
what i was up against the whole game
this knight d4 move is so annoying
and i didn't see a follow-up in this
position
now i thought in this position maybe we
can go for example bishop f4 to b8
what is the idea of the move bishop b8
and
remember this type of idea because it's
going to recur
so what is the purpose of dropping the
bishop back in general
well it's to
set up what it's to set up queen f4 it's
to set up a battery and that battery is
going to yield two methods but
unfortunately i calculated the following
line
knight d2
and at first glance you might ah queen
f4 is a fork
we fork the knight and the other knight
and if knight takes e2
then queen h2 king f1
quinn h1 made
but then you look a little bit more
carefully it's not mate white has knight
g1
blocking the check and if we play bishop
h2 it still looks like it should be made
but it's not the other knight comes to
the rescue knight f3 and black loses
and if we play rook takes d2 then queen
ca check and white wins the bishop and
wins the game black's attack fizzles out
so i calculated this line
by the way after queen f4 even if knight
takes c2 failed
white also has the move knight f3
defending h2 the other knight defends
then on f3 look at this division of
labor for white and everything is held
together
everything is held together
so that was rejected
i rejected bishop e4
for a very similar reason because rick
takes the a to knight t4 and it didn't
i didn't
quite
figure out
what oops not rook d7 but take stakes
knight t4 and i didn't understand
why the bishop is better placed on e4
than it is on e2
also after bishop e4
white has a very annoying second move
can anybody find it other than
rook takes the a check
who can spot the second annoying idea
and it's not knight d4
because if you go knight d4 here and i
also calculated this
what is the drawback of the move knight
d4
well it opens up the light squared
bishop what is the light squared bishop
doing
well it's pressuring the pawn on g2
can we increase the pressure on the pawn
on g2 we can we can play queen g6 what
do we notice here we notice two things
the first we're threatening mate
our bishops can be used as battering
rams if the pawn goes to g3 we
automatically take country 3 and we're
crushing
if the pawn goes to f3 we take on f3
using the pin against the rook on d1 if
the knight takes then we win the rook
and we win the game it's made
but unfortunately there is the move
knight b to d2
developing attacking the line does not
end there
the line does not end there black has a
move which may seem to win material
bishop c2
and you think ah i'm attacking the rook
and the rook has to move and then you
take the knight on d2
unfortunately if you look concretely
white has rook c1
attacking the bishop
and if the bishop moves away the rook
moves back to d1 and i was not able to
find a follow-up here either i think
white holds on
so this took me a while to calculate and
on the basis of these lines i decided
that we're going to play b6 and see how
that impacts the game
so b6 queen before a5 continuing to
chase the queen around and here i think
white made a critical mistake
here i think actually maybe not because
if white plays queen queen a4
um no actually i do think that white
made a mistake
but i'm not totally sure because
wherever the queen goes we can continue
tossing the queen around if queen b3 we
can play a4
if queen a4 we can play b5
and in either way we continue moving
tossing the queen around
we continue tossing the queen around
so
again this is what lends the position a
tremendous deal of complexity the fact
that
the fact that
white has a million alternatives and
black has a million alternatives
and who the heck knows where white
should put his queen it's impossible to
say so queen b4 and queen a3 makes a lot
of sense
the one thing i will say
is that if white had been going to a3 he
should have gone queen a3 immediately
can anybody explain to me why it is a
bad idea
to induce the move a7 a5 why does the
pawn being on a5 favor black and if you
paid attention to the way the game went
this should be an easier question
more escape squares yes that's true
but the main reason if you remember
later in the game i played the move
bishop d6
and when the pawn is on a5
after bishop d6 b4 we can play a takes
before and open up an attack on the
queen here if black ever plays bishop d6
and white plays b4 the queen is safe
with the pawn on a5 there's the move a
takes before so the pawn on a5 restricts
the queen further and makes b4 less
effective so
again hard to see
so another critical position here now
with the queen on a3 you have to
recalculate the same lines that we
calculated before so i took a look at
bishop e2
i took a look at this position
but even with the queen banished to a3 i
did not find a way forward maybe the
engine will see something here maybe
there's a crazy move like bishop f3 or
maybe there's a quiet move like queen g6
there's an amazing idea i
originally was tempted by queen g6 with
the idea of putting the bishop on f3
remember that the knight cannot move
because of the back rank mate who can
spot a very nasty move here for white
not king h1 folks
i think white wins material
lpdo the rook on d8 is undefended the
bishop on e2 is incredibly vulnerable
remember that pieces that were one
second ago incredibly passive can become
game-winning pieces queen a3 to e7
forking the rook and the bishop on e2
and the queen can take the bishop bunny
two
look how nasty and how easy this stuff
is to miss
especially from a distance
so
after
further reflection i all of a sudden
realized that the queen is almost
trapped and that's when i discovered the
idea of dropping the bishop back to d6
but if you do it immediately then the
queen still has the b3 square
oh my god but
oh my goodness if you do it immediately
actually maybe it's even better
oh this is beautiful
after queen b3 who can tell me black's
winning move
who can tell me black's winning move no
i think this was the way to go i think
this was the win
or maybe not the win but maybe at least
a4
the queen is no squares wherever you go
bishop h2 check and both pieces are
responsible for the queen being trapped
either the rook or the queen isn't that
awesome queen b6 the queen x-rays the
queen queen d5 the rook x-rays the queen
so
white is forced to play b4
a takes b4 and queen b2 and at the very
least i think black can play bishop
takes b1 and b takes c3 and i think
black has to be winning here because
queen b6 there's a fork with c2 tactics
absolutely everywhere i didn't see
bishop b60 i assumed that we have to
cover the b3 square before going bishop
d6 i made an assumption
and rook d4 i think was an excellent
defensive move i honestly missed it what
i calculated was rook takes d8 rook
takes the knight t4 you know the drill
and now we play bishop d6 and here's
what i calculated b4
a takes b4
sorry a takes b4
queen b2
and now
black i think has a simplifying
combination that wins the game
i think the simplest here for black
is to play
what
who can tell me
what black should do here
and i think if you are accurate you
should be able to win this handily
he takes c3
yeah very good
even bishop h7 is crushing yeah bishop
h7
or bishop g6 is just totally crushing
because white is completely and utterly
paralyzed very instructive move by the
way but
if you want to play concretely i think
you can play b take c3
queen takes bishop queen takes knight
if queen takes e3 this is checkmate
if knight takes c3
then we go
oh we go rook c8
oh but here white has rook d1 so maybe
this is a little bit more complicated
even though this is probably still
winning
i agree with jose and i think that black
should just drop the bishop back to g6
and it's complete and total paralysis
just look at this position
and make sure you understand why black
is winning here because that's very
instructive black is completely winning
here it's probably plus seven
because the moment you play c takes
before the knight loses its defender and
black skewers the knight 500 different
ways
does that make sense
so
for that reason rook d4 is an excellent
defensive move rook d4 instead of rook
takes dh check
okay
so we play bishop d6 y plays b4 and of
course the key difference is that the d
file is now
being debated black is not controlling
the d file
so we play a takes b4
now i almost played bishop takes before
which is another move that has to be
calculated what is the purpose of bishop
takes before well here's what i
calculated
if white plays c takes b4
then we play rook takes d4 knight takes
queen ticks and black is doing great the
rook is hanging
the rook is hanging
white can defend with knight c3
now what should black do here subs are
always appreciated but never
uh
obligatory black to play and find the
most accurate move rook c8 excellent i
love that you guys weren't attracted
with queen takes before is winning but
rook c8 simply wins the knight
if queen c3
then we have a choice queen d1 check or
queen takes c3 and a b followed by b3
and this is even easier we play b3 and
then b2 is unstoppable the rook is
hanging if white takes on b3
so that's all good and well and good but
it's not checkers and after bishop takes
before white can drop the queen back to
tim cannon poker with a five
oh man what a hype stream more subs
more subs
thank you i appreciate it
holy cannoli
all right guys give me another second
all right
so bishop takes before queen b2 and i
simply did not find a good follow-up
here
does that make sense so far is everybody
following the arc of the game thus far
so for that reason we play a takes
before and after queen b2
another very important position occurs
so
what's happening here what's going on
well this is a pretty simple position
the bishop is hanging
and we do not want to play bishop takes
b1 it is not in our best interest to
trade pieces here because with every
trade white's defensive task becomes a
little bit easier
and after rook takes b1
at best maybe black is slightly better
but i don't even think black can get a
slight advantage here
oh it's the top engine move so maybe i'm
wrong maybe this is the best way to go
rook takes a2
maybe you go like this
maybe you go like this and went upon not
sure and um if rook takes b6 here
can anybody spot the game-winning tactic
for black
can anybody spot the game-winning tactic
for black i didn't see any of this to be
completely honest with you i did not
even consider bishop takes b1
because why would you give away one of
your amazing bishops for white's
undeveloped knight but i guess
concretely and we'll check this with the
engine concretely black wins on
on a2
yeah bishop h2 bang bang bang bang bang
bang rook takes b6 and bishop h2 check
and after knight takes h2 queen takes b6
we're simultaneously defending the rook
on the e8 black wins
or sorry no here you have mate here here
you have mate
but of course white will play king h2
and after queen b6 black should be able
to win
so instead i decided to keep the bishops
and keep the tension bishop g6 c takes
b4
so
now
it would be very nice if we could play
the move bishop e5 but we can't
because remember
the dark scored bishop is crucial
because the bishop is controlling h2 so
in order to keep alive the threat of
backrank checkmate we must keep the
bishop alive if you play bishop e5
that's a horrible blunder because you
give away the bishop and you're like oh
this is checkmate it's not made anymore
you've given away your dark square
bishop so the king is h2 at best you can
win back the knight but black is going
to be down upon
so for that reason i decided on the same
idea but different execution bishop
drops back to c7 and the whole point
here is that if white takes on d8 and
then takes on f6 and tries to simplify
why does one move away from completing
his development but this is where the
mate happens rook d1 and rook takes c1
is checkmate
rook d1 rook takes you on his checkmate
so
where does that leave us
so in this position
white our opponent played the move
knight c3 and here the game enters
uh the sort of decisive stage where we
tried to win this night
i think and we will check this with the
engine i think white's decisive mistake
was to play rook takes the 8 check and
give away the d5 i think giving away the
d file is something that white simply
cannot afford to do in this end game who
can tell me what white's alternative was
in this position
what was white's alternative and not
just alternative i think the only way to
stay in the game
yeah and bd2 and bd2
remember if you play rook d2
people are forgetting about the back do
not forget about the back rank mate
queen b2 rugby 2 rook d1 is simply
checkmate
knight bd2 i think holds on amazingly i
think white holds here
rook takes d4
and now i think even queen takes d4
holds
so what i actually missed
initially i thought that we could take
and play bishop e5 and i thought that
this pin would be devastating but simply
white plays knight df-3 and okay black
is not worse here obviously we have two
amazing bishops but white should be able
to hold a draw at this point
so amazingly after knight bd2 i do not
see a clear way for black to gain the
advantage
i just don't see
difficult move to play just keeping the
tension our opponent very understandably
wanted to release the tension and play
knight c3 but after rook d3 all of a
sudden the problems that are facing
white become insurmountable now all of
this hinges on one very important tactic
knight a4 unpins the queen and offers a
queen trade looks pretty good for white
who can spot the game-winning tactic and
i mentioned this during the game so if
you were paying attention you should
know what it is probably not the only
one here but it's definitely the
simplest it's definitely the simplest
yeah rook takes f3
notice that this defends the queen
simultaneously
so if queen takes f6 we play rook takes
up six and we win the piece gf3 bishop
e5 pinning the queen and winning the
rook and black is gonna be up in peace
now probably you can play queen g5 check
here and mate the king my guess is that
there is a mating attack here somewhere
to be found but
in your pocket you have bishop e5
that means
white must defend the knight and the
only way to do that is rook c1 but now
the rook is vulnerable so we play bishop
f4 and after rook c2 this is maybe the
toughest position of the whole game for
me i could not for the life of me find
the winning move here
so most of you are probably like why the
hell didn't you go rook takes f3
but the pro oh first of all queen takes
c3
it's an illusion it looks like it's made
and after rook takes c3 it is indeed
checkmate or d1 but
queen takes c3
rook d1 checkmate
it's not checkmate black uh white plays
91 in the queen defense tonight and
white survives and white survives and
after bishop takes c2 it may seem that
black has compensation who can spot the
winning idea for white white has a very
pretty geometric uh move that wins
immediately who can find it
quincy a check very good queen takes c2
and you win the rook
so
that doesn't work
rook takes f3 of course i was as tempted
as you are by this move but after gf i
could not for the life of me figure out
the winning move and maybe
we'll check with the engine maybe rook
takes f3 here was winning
couldn't find it either but here the
reason i rejected this is because of the
following so first of all
why not bishop takes to do well here
white plays queen takes c2 and white is
over the worst of it right
so what's the tempting move here
what's the tempting move here
oh it's it's queen g5 check right looks
mating
but the problem i think is that the king
runs toward the center king f1
now you might say oh i see made in two
bishop d3 checking you one queen g1 is
checkmate and it is
but of course white can block with the
knight and in this position i spent a
while thinking about this i couldn't
find the win
now that i look at this closer i think
queen to f5 might be a winning move i
think queen to f5 might be winning
because it attacks the rook but mainly
it attacks the pawn oh but here why does
king g2
here white has king g2
and if black takes on c2 white takes on
f4 and the queen is overloaded you
either take the knight or you keep the
bishop defended so
hopefully you can see that it's not as
easy as it looks to win this i'm sure
that it's winning but i just couldn't
find the move especially in light of the
fact that i that i found this very
interesting idea bishop f5 which i'm
sure is incorrect according to the
engine but i think it's a very cool move
and the idea is to open up the g6 square
for the queen to open up that square for
the queen why is it important to open up
that square for the queen
because if white plays a4 rook takes f3
gf and queen g6 for kuruskis
for that reason i just did not see a
satisfactory defense for white
knight e1
rook d8 and at this point the game is
over
at this point the game is over
because
we attack the rook
the rook has to move
and now we play very simple move bishop
e5 and at the end of the day what kills
white fittingly enough is the knight on
c3 that is what loses the game for white
and what's interesting is that we have
used the d file to our advantage but we
actually
exit the d file to win the game we play
rook c8 and the game is over
how to find a move like well
you have to not lose sight of the
overall
sort of dynamic of the position the fact
of the matter is that the knight on c3
is white's weakest piece
it's white's weakest piece so yes you
can go after white's king
but ultimately going after the knight on
c3 makes the most sense now maybe white
has some sort of computer defense here i
don't see it
i just don't see it i think black is
already winning
now we're going to check with the
computer we're going to check a couple
of critical we're not going to check
every every line every critical moment
first thing we're going to check
we're going to look at
okay so
rook d8
bishop f5 bishop d3 is correct
yep top move actually the only move to
get an edge
b6 is also correct
okay bishop b2 actually was very good
here
rook d8 rook d8 knight t4
oh and bishop d6
ah queen b3 queen f4
win b3 queen f4 knight takes c2
check check oh and now bishop h2 we
literally looked at an almost identical
idea but there the knight was on d2 so
the knight could jump into f3 to the
knight's rescue here the knight cannot
do that so we play queen takes g1 and we
win
amazing
amazing so bishop b2 was winning but a5
is good
bishop c2 is not good bishop e2 was the
winning move
i simply missed
the idea of going bishop d6 and queen f4
i underestimated it
i underestimated that idea
so instead we went bishop c2 rook d4
very strong bishop d6 is good
before we're still winning
yeah bishop takes b1 actually was the
top engine move but bishop g6 keeps a
big advantage
um bishop c7 is a mistake apparently
bishop f8 was the move
and the idea is to keep in contact with
the pawn on b4 so that after rook takes
d4
we can trade queens take before and
black is much better because the bishops
are totally monstrous here totally
monstrous
totally monstrous
bishop c7
and
as we predicted this is the decisive
mistake knight bd2 and white is only
slightly worse black actually has
nothing better than to take on d4
so amazing defense by our opponent up
until the very last moment
yep bishop f5 it's the second move look
bishop f5 is the second engine move it's
almost as good as rook takes f3 and
bishop e5
if not better it's literally just as
good so bishop f5 i'm proud of finding
rogue d8
and bishop e5 is correct so at the end i
played very accurately
at the end i played very accurately
so
just a really really interesting game
not without mistakes and as you can see
i also made mistakes in handling the
complexities of the position but
i you know i found good moves when push
came to shove but my main mistake
actually was not seeing
this idea of going bishop
e2 either in this position or
in this position bishop e2
takes takes knight t4 i stopped
calculating too soon i didn't see bishop
d6 queen b3 queen f4 with the dual
threat of queen c1 queen h2 and
at the end of the day bishop h2 is
crushing because the king is driven out
into the wide open space and just check
made it easily
beautiful
that's a lovely game but let's end it
here because i want the youtube video to
be below two hours so i want to thank
everybody for watching thanks for
hanging out and hope you enjoyed the
speedrun game bye
[Music]